but let's crack into this one today i am
honored to have one of new zealand's
greatest lads with me
he is a genuine all-round good sort he
may not have played professionally but
it's fair to say he's been the face of
sport
for a very long time he's also the host
of new zealand's favorite podcast and
staff chat
and i know he's had some uni along the
way it is the great man himself
mark steffen welcome stevie thanks for
coming on mate
jimmy i appreciate the work you put into
your intros mate makes you feel good
that's
who would have thought that you would be
interviewing me after all those years
ago when i first met you and i gave you
a lesson on how to be a bookmaker
and you've interviewed me a lot
throughout my career so it's quite nice
to be able to turn around on youtube
nice we'll see how you go but i do
remember that um
in wellington when you came in you saw
my bookmaking odds for the surf to peak
and
you saw that my market was way off
i didn't want to have anyone at two
higher odds because i didn't want to
have to pay anyone out so
you caught me on that and taught me a
lesson and made me
bump a few prices up yeah yeah your
percentages were so far out but you were
a sponge mate you really wanted to know
oh no we can't have kellen givens too
high we can't have him too like
snakey will win yeah like five guys
under three dollars it was just a
wrought
i still took the money
[Laughter]
i still had panthers coming oh the boys
love a punt
yeah as i'm sure you'd imagine
but anyway got a lot to get through with
you so um let's start right back at the
start
um take us right back to what it was
like for a little staff growing up
yeah it was um interesting we moved
around a lot actually born in gisborne
and um but we left there when i was i
think
four yeah went to hamilton started
school in hamilton we were only there
for 18 months then went to christchurch
and we were there about two years and
then
i started school in hamilton only
briefly then a couple of years or so in
christchurch that's where i started
playing rugby when i was
five and a half for linwood
and the mighty linwood fergie mccormick
country and then
up to palmerston north and so i'd lived
in four cities by the time i was seven
dad was a rep for the europa oil company
that was
subsequently brought out by bp a few
years later
and then we settled in palmy so i grew
up in palmy did all my pretty much all
my schooling and palmy and went to palmy
boys
played rugby right from as i say from
five till i was
16 um and then had a bit of a car
accident
and could never play rugby again which
was guthing because
it was in my sixth form year and um
we had an awesome first fifteen at palmy
boys that year we actually had the
myasca cup
and uh yeah it was a it was an awesome
first fifteen and i just made the second
15
we had trials i knew i wouldn't make the
firsts um
but i made the second 15 which we used
to play all the other first 15s around
the
district but then yeah a shocker of a
car accident and
the first tuesday of the may school
holiday so never got to play
play a game jeez so what were you like
at rugby were you quite talented in what
position
well i was quite lucky that like from
when i first shifted to palmy
i was the second five my whole life i
was the second five
and um i had a first five by the name of
gareth williams
and uh he was unbelievable he was a
little guy but
just he was like dmacc you know he he
was just a freak
and i played outside him from when i was
seven
right through primary school
intermediate secondary school he made
the first 15 the year i made the seconds
but he made me look good mate i was
lucky i had a bit of pace actually jimmy
yeah and uh yeah i had a bit of pace and
he was
rapid and i was about the only person in
the team and the juniors that could keep
up with him
so my instructions were just to run on
his shoulder and if he needed help which
he really did
yeah um was to just i was the man in
support but his classic move was
like half back to first five in the open
side and he'd just
loop around and run down the blind side
no i can catch him he'd just run the
sideline and score tries and
he was a freak he was a freak did you
ever think about
making rugby as a career or um progress
progressing it
any further no well it wasn't
professional then
and it was just i mean in those days
there was just club
and then um like the palmy boys were
staying played saturdays
under 21 grade um against kyoto and high
school boys and all that sort of thing
and then they'd play these school games
on a sunday or a wednesday and that sort
of thing and then as i say
our first 15 but then the progression
from that was you'd go school then leave
school go under 21s and then you'd
hopefully get
as a young fella and 21-22 was young to
make a provincial side so your next step
would be
manoa two and then all blacks you know
no super rugby
and um but you know manual two was
strong
they had the shield when i was a little
fella in 78
and that was awesome and i actually
played a um
curtain raiser to a curtain raiser to a
spring box game
so i made them i made the manual to
under 12
reps um thanks to gareth williams
because he was the first five
so yeah i got and i've still got the
jersey and uh
and then i was ball boy for the main
game so that's about as high a stage as
i got jimmy
and then talk to me about this car crash
obviously it must have been pretty bad
to
stop you from playing rugby ever again
yeah so i had um
a good mate of mine aaron he was he was
the hooker
in the second 15 and he was from shannon
and his girlfriend lived in opi which is
the spud farming capital of the country
and um he was playing club he was
playing second 15
for parmi and then he was playing for
shannon seniors
who played in the horror final
competition in the weekend so we were
going down
on the tuesday for his training and
shannon and he was dropping us off at
his girlfriend's place
and um garrus williams his
girlfriend so the first of them were
touring in australia his girlfriend was
in the passenger seat i was in the back
seat
and we we'd head on with a truck and it
was
actually parked on the road at 6 30 at
night middle of winter so
um pitch black didn't have his lights on
and he was facing us on our side of the
road on the road
and we just throw straight into it never
saw it yeah
and so the driver he was thrown out um
he was thrown out of the car out the
door so he sort of
hit and um the door flew open he flew
out there i went over the back seat and
into the i ended up
in the um dashboard really and when the
police and the ambulance were up they
thought i was the driver because i was
in the driver's seat because i'd come
over the front
and megan who was in the passenger sheet
she went through the windscreen into the
truck she died
instantly and i was um
it was kind of weird jimmy like i didn't
i don't remember it i still don't
remember the the crash but
i woke up in hospital and intensive care
and um and the weird thing was i didn't
remember the crash
but and i couldn't open my eyes and my
mum was sitting next to me on the bed
and i knew what had happened but i don't
know how i knew what had happened
and then about a week later they moved
me out of intensive care
and the ambulance driver came into the
uh
hospital room and he had like this big
fuzzy ginger here
and a big fuzzy ginger bed so it's
really distinctive looking and i'd only
just opened my eyes and i looked at him
and i went oh
ambulance like this and the ambulance
driver said oh
how does he know i was the ambulance
driver and she goes i guess he
recognizes you and he said but
you know i was i was actually dead when
they when they got me and they and they
brought me back
like a couple of times in the ambulance
and um but i recognized them and then my
memory was
i was looking down on the crash scene
and that's how i saw him and
and i was looking at this crash scene
was like a dream and i was like
oh what's going on down there and it was
like oh that's me
oh that's and and then i woke up and i
was in intensive care
and then a number of years later and i'm
probably talking
five or six years later i was watching a
movie
and it was nicole kidman and tom cruise
and they were an irish couple
and it was when the land grab was on in
america and they basically everyone was
on their horse and they said go and you
could ride out and go and stick your
flag in a piece of land
and that you claim that as your farm and
tom cruise fell off his horse and hit
his head
on a rock yeah and the camera did this
big spiral
up and looking down on him like that was
his spirit and i
said to my girlfriend i said that that's
what happened to me and it took me back
to and then i understood what had
actually happened so
and i'm not a religious person i'm not a
spiritual person or anything like that
but
i guess that's what they call an
out-of-body experience and um yes i was
looking down on the crash scene of me
being loaded into the ambulance
and um yeah and so i didn't
that sort of ruined uh all contact sport
basically i had a massively
bruised brain and they said it would
take five years for the blood to drain
from the brain
and so um any tap
i got partial amnesia so i'd forgot i
forgot
everything and everyone i'd met in the
previous six months
except the ambulance except absolutely
but i looked at my school books from the
first term and i could see it was my
handwriting but i didn't remember
writing any of it
and new people at school that were in my
class i didn't know who they were
yeah but but i knew the people from
there before so
i spent a long time in hospital and then
a long time
going to specialists and stuff for the
rest of the year so i completely
failed at sixth form because i just
wasn't there
and so i did two years and sixth form
but yeah i couldn't play rugby anymore
so
um i i pretty much didn't do any sport
that yeah i started playing basketball
the year after which was probably a
no-no because that's still semi-contact
but
you know i took up swimming i did golf i
tried snooker
darts anything you know indoor bowls
i really must really miss the rugby
and i remember when i was about 24 so
like eight years later
um i went to have a brain scan and i got
the all clear that i could play
so i went to kyota and i said i want to
play
and been eight years and so i got to
start i got a game with the prezis
yeah so i go along to the prezis and
they said oh where do you want to play
and i said oh i'm the second five and
they said oh we've got heaps of backs he
said
we'll chuck you on the side of the scrum
some play blindside flank out
and after about two minutes there's this
huge lock
running straight at me and i i went down
a tackle i should let him through i was
just
i was just too scared and then i looked
at the coach and i said take me off
you know i didn't want to play scared
but i was so scared of getting knocked
in the head but
so i'm pleased i had that two or three
minutes because it had been an
itch for eight years yeah and until i
was confronted with that situation i
realized man i was just so
scared of getting hit and you as you
know you can't play rugby skid
banks he's made a career out of it but
he has a yeah i must ask him what he'd
not thanks his head
and ronan ogara he's done all right
[Laughter]
oh but anyway have you got any long-term
effects from that
incident or is everything now fully
sweet
um i'm still i still um
what's the best way to describe it i'm
terrible with um
so i get real travel sickness really bad
so anything to do with your what like
dizziness
like yeah i can't go on the um circus
rides and stuff like that because i'll
pass out because i've just got
no resilience in my head yeah i probably
get
one or two massive migraines a year yeah
and then when i was about i struggled
with the years but
probably i must have been about
uh 29 so maybe 10 years later
i was having massive dizzy spells
like almost to the point i couldn't walk
like i was having to hold the walls to
walk
and i was like that for three months and
long story short i was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis
and um i went to about
six or seven gps yeah um before
i finally went to one and he said it
sounds like multiple sclerosis and i
said oh another gp said that but
they said that's a woman's disease
because i didn't even know what it was
yeah so what is that
so it's um it's
well i don't want to get too medical on
you but it's you get lesions on your
brain
and so you've got on the nerve endings
in your brain you've got these
protective
like sheaths on your brain on the nerve
endings in your brain to look after them
because if
if you've got exposed nerves on anything
it hurts like hell
yeah so but your body thinks that those
sheaths are an infection and it attacks
them
so you've got your body attacking your
own nerves
and so and it usually affects your your
vision and your bladder are the two
the two normal ones so a lot of people
with ms get double vision
and trouble with incontinence and stuff
and those two things didn't affect me
but i basically had pins and needles
over 100 of my body 100 of the day
and like pins and needles in my lungs
pins and needles and just
everywhere because it was like all my
nerves were just alive
and so and it took so long for them to
diagnose me like the first sick dog
first six gps just said i had stress i
just had stress and i had to relax i
said mate
the only thing i've got stressed about
is you bastard's telling me i've got
stress
you know so once i got the diagnosis
i um i went into into i
became a day patient and i for three
days i got like
massive doses of intravenous steroids
yeah and like i hadn't been eating i'd
lost so much weight
because i couldn't eat i was i was
stressed because i knew there was
something wrong with me and i
i dropped down to about 80 kilos and um
and then i went on these steroids and i
kid you not mate like
holy heck if you want to put on weight
take a massive dose of intravenous
steroids because
i in about four weeks i'd gone up to 110
kilos
and i was just a fat bastard today but i
was
like my mum would come down to
wellington and cook me a week's worth of
meals i'd eat it in a day
i was having seven meals a day i was
ravenous
because the steroids the steroids just
kills
everything inside your stomach that
takes the nutrients out of your food so
you have a meal
your body doesn't get any nutrients so
you're still hungry so you just keep
eating
yeah i was oh [ __ ] i was fat it was um
it was interesting but then i re then i
really went on to the um
natural health side of things and i got
in touch with a woman in auckland
she's actually a pharmacist but she's
into natural health in alternative ways
and
i was just chucking like evening
primrose oil vitamin e salmon oil
vitamin b um various amino acids i was
spending a fortune
but i hammond my body with natural
defense
yeah and touchwood i've never had
another ms attack since
so um about
15 percent of people with ms that's cool
you can benign so you have one attack
and don't have another one
so i'm lucky that i'm one of the 15
um most people they'll have an attack
like
every seven years then every six years
then every five years and it gets closer
and closer as you get older and older
and
you end up being you know wheelchairs
immobilized it affects your speech
and all that so you still have your
marbles but um
you wouldn't think so by looking from
the outside so
yeah i did a bit of fundraising and
stuff and i used to go and speak at the
newly diagnosed
sessions for new ms patients and try and
help them and give them some hope and
all that sort of stuff so that was a
that was a hell of a chapter
geez your body's been through been
through the ringer yeah
just got hammered oh yeah and you've
also you're also a cancer survivor too
aren't you so do you want to talk about
it yeah mate
yeah that was um that was probably about
um five or six years after that and um
yeah and i i didn't have any pain or
anything so i got testicular cancer
and you know you don't really know i was
feeling a little bit
off not sick or anything just just felt
like i was about 95
all the time yeah and then my girlfriend
she just said you know one of your plums
is twice the size of the other one
and i said oh yeah that's you baby
and she said you better go and get it
checked out and i know it doesn't hurt
you know
you know i don't know maybe you're not
you know you'd google it and yeah
sometimes
one's bigger than the other but i went
to the doctor and he said i don't think
it's anything sinister but we'll get an
ultrasound so i went and had an
ultrasound and i'm looking up at the
screen as the girl's doing the
ultrasound
annoying and i just said [ __ ] that
doesn't look good yeah i said what does
that look like to you she goes oh i
can't say but i could tell by her face
there's something wrong and she says
we'll give the results back to your
doctor
and i said oh okay so i thought i had
like a hematoma or a cyst or something
like that
yeah and um i got in the car left the
radiology place
and i'd only been in the car five
minutes and my gp rung me
he said mate no way to sugarcoat this
you've got testicular cancer
and i was like you are [ __ ] joking me
you know after all this [ __ ]
and and i remember um i pulled
like i pulled over i was halfway back to
work so i sort of between home and work
and i pulled over and i pulled my eyes
out and it was like
and i didn't sort of know why and it was
and i don't think it was because
i had cancer was just like another
bloody thing you know
and um and then i thought oh so i just
went home
and um and i thought oh this is a waste
of time and so i just went into work
and told them
and then um i can't admit i can't
exactly remember how it happened but i
ended up i had
health insurance so i think within a
week
i was in a private hospital and they
basically cut your stomach open sort of
level with your belly button and then
like
your testicle your your nut is connected
to this tube that goes from
from your ball bag up to up to something
and they basically pull it out
and then they slip the tube tie knot and
then sew up your stomach
and the most painful part was because
they cut through all your abdominal
muscles
every time you move just the grab of
your abdominal muscles like
anyone that's had a hernia operation or
something or a cesarean and stuff like
that they know how
because you your abs are locking all the
time and yeah
and so went home and got over that sort
of operation and then they test you
and so they said if you're a bloke
testicular cancer if you're going to get
cancer is the best one because it's so
far away from the rest of your organs
and stuff so
yeah the risk of it spreading is light
because it can only travel through that
tube so they take that whole tube out
so i got blood tested like within days
and they said my mark of count was fine
and then
i was having a blood test every two
weeks
and about four six months after the
operation
they said oh it's back the cancer's back
and i'm like oh where and they said oh
we're not sure but you know most marker
counts uh
and a normal person like everyone's got
cancer cells in them yeah
and your and and they there's like
cancer marker counts out of a hundred so
a normal person's from memory is about
between four and ten
yeah so i'd have my had my test and i
was like eight
seven six eleven eight four and i was
going along like that four ninety nines
that's all right and i was about to drop
back to uh once every two months blood
test and then
i got a marker reading of 95. and
yeah it had come soaring back and so i
went into work
i went to the specialist and he said
mate because we took the tumor out we
know what sort of cancer it is
we we're not legally we're not allowed
to say we can cure it but i'm 99.9
we've got it we've got a chemo that will
fix that
so and i said but it does knock the [ __ ]
out of you this
chemo regime you're going to go through
no i know so i told work took three
months off work organized
got all my fears in order and and one of
the managers at work that i got on
really well was he was in the cancer
ward and so they
had a bed for me next to him and we
could just shoot the [ __ ] while we're
going through this
bloody awful time together so i go to
the hospital with my sister and my
father to admit me in and then and then
the last thing they do before they start
you on the chemo is they take your
height
your weight and um in a blood test
to to figure out how much chemo you're
going to go on so took my heart took my
weight
gotten my hospital pajamas and then they
came in and they said ah
your blood tests come back normal you
know what
and they said yeah you're just back to
normal and i said well
someone's lying you know what you know
i'd prepared myself to go through hell
and then they're telling me i could go
home
and it was normal i said test me again
and so they did
and it was normal and like my father and
my sister were stoked but i was
so pissed off like you'd think you'd be
happy yeah
but i wasn't and and i was in the
hospital i said just [ __ ] give it to
me anyway because i was so
i was so ready for it and um
so i ended up going home and went back
to work the next day and they're like
what are you doing here so well i'm
clearer again so
for about the next three or four years i
was having an x-ray every
three months in an mri every six months
blood tests every month and
i was just a bloody pincushion and to
this day that's never come back
so yeah it was um it was horrendous mate
it was uh
it was horrendous but i think i dealt
with the cancer diagnosis
better than than someone who'd never had
anything wrong with them
yeah because because i'd been through
the horrendous characters and i'd been
through the
ms thing and then the cancer one was
like oh well it's just a friggin
another one it didn't make me stronger
it just made me realise you actually can
win these things yeah um that's not the
and when you get a cancer diagnosis
people think it's a death notice
as well and when i was diagnosed i
since learned that it was back then it
was something like
90 of people that get diagnosed with
cancer survive
oh really yeah so it's really high
and the number of people when i because
it's sort of embarrassing as a bloke to
say testicular cancer
but the number of people that came said
i've had that my brother said that my
father had that my cousin had that it's
cancer is so common yeah so what was the
go with the positive test did you ever
find out
how you had 95 percent
so like i said to that it was professor
daidy who was the foremost oncologist in
new zealand
and i said how does that happen i just
need to know how that happens
like is it human error is it you know
and i don't care what it is
i just need to be able to label what it
was you know
and he had been like a professor of
oncology for 20 years and he said this
is
only the third time in my career i've
seen it happen and he said
i can't explain it like your body he
said the 95 was correct
and the four that we get today is
correct how your body's done that i
don't know
so he said i'm sorry i can't explain it
what experience for you with in terms of
your body you've been through
absolute ring ass but anyway i want to
get to um sort of your work everyone
knows you're the face of
the tab the face of sport in new zealand
um how did you get into that and where
did that all start
yeah so i was um i'd had a few little
bits and people like my my first career
out of
school was actually insurance and i
worked for state insurance
and in my days when you left school at
palmy
uh palmy boys you you could like
apply to what was it called the state
services commission and they basically
staffed all of the government
departments
so i was really good with numbers and i
wanted to be an accountant and
so i applied to them and said i'd like
to go to the inland revenue
because and then revenue put you through
university paid for it
and you could get your chartered
accountant's license and all that sort
of stuff so
that was sort of the path i wanted and
being from palmy boys
i mean no one went on the dole everyone
got a job it wasn't wasn't a big deal
you either went to university or you
went working and i didn't want to go to
university i was
i was sick of people standing at the
front of the room telling me stuff that
i didn't really want to know about you
know i just wanted to go out and
you know get a car and car stereo and
you know
that sort of stuff and so i i got down
to
inland revenue we're going to take two
graduates
to two school leavers and um so i got
down to the last four
and uh and i went to the last interview
but the day before the last interview i
flattered with a um
hairdresser and the day before was the
man with two hairdressing champs
and so i model i modeled for him and so
i had like i turned after this interview
with
um black around the sides white on the
top and a big red rat's tail
because it's actually the best
hairdressing the best dudes was that or
yeah it came second at the moment of two
chances yeah came second
and um yes i go to this interview and
didn't get the job because of my haircut
and and then the guy that was doing the
employing was a mate of my father's and
he rang dad and told him my
dad kicked me up the assay so i really
got my ear cut and colored and got a job
at state insurance
[Laughter]
yeah so i was there for a few years and
then i did some sales repping and then i
worked for income support for a while um
but i really wanted to get into the tab
because i love to punt
and um and i was betting offshore
because
new zealand didn't have sports building
at that time and um
being new zealand to theab announced
they were going to do sports betting so
i
i wrote to them and said i want to be a
bookmaker you know because i kept all my
own figures i had
like these books yeah so i had i had an
account at centerbit and an account at
darwin all sports
and i used to keep log books so where
i'd bet and how much i'd win how much
i'd lose and
and i said to him i said to myself i
wouldn't
i wouldn't add up the columns till i'd
been going a year
yeah because i didn't want to influence
how i was betting so at the end of the
year
i'd like it seemed a bit i'd lost 800
bucks
and on darwin all sports i'd made about
1400.
oh yeah so i canceled i cancelled my
centipede account thinking it was their
fault
and kept the darwin and and i loved it i
just
loved it i loved the challenge and i
wasn't beating big but i was betting
often
because to me it was like not the size
of the wind but getting a win you know
even if it was a ten dollar bit on
something for
that i'd figured out that they'd had
wrong so i was always looking for
not necessarily mistakes but i was i was
hunting value bits and i'd find one you
know
um so i didn't get a job at the tib
and then as sports betting expanded i
um kept applying and i never got the job
and i found out they were employing from
within so i applied for other jobs at
the tib just so i could get in and i got
one of those
um sort of a little bit fraudulently um
they said have you done um qa before and
i said yeah yeah done that it's awesome
i didn't even know what it was
so i got got a job as a qa tester at the
tab
and after three months i said oh you're
a really good rooster but you don't know
what you're doing
so they moved me somewhere else that's
pretty impressive
yeah yeah and yeah and then i suppose
i've been there about a year and a year
and a half and then i joined the sports
betting team
and as a junior bookmaker and sort of
the couple of years as a junior and
learning my craft and
and then i became so you have a junior
bookmaker a bookmaker
and a senior bookmaker seen i was a
bookmaker for a while
and then about the same times i became a
senior bookmaker was when
[Music]
part of my job was i used to fax the
odds to sky
to put on a graphic before games and
and the producer rang me one day and
said you know thanks for sitting through
the faxes do you want to come down to
the stadium and do it on screen
i said what do you mean she's like talk
on camera you know just give the odds
on camera and i said i've never done
that before she goes oh you'll be fine
yeah
so i said to my boss they want me to do
it on tv and they say oh really oh
if you want to you can so i said okay so
i did one game i did
um hurricanes crusaders at westpac
stadium
and um and afterwards she came up to me
she goes that was awesome um
do you want to come up to auckland and
do it next next week
on friday night oh and that's
sort of where it started just started
doing friday night super rugby games and
then it became friday saturday and then
it became all blacks and then we just
started doing npc and then
cricket boxing netball the whole lot it
was um
it was awesome so you'd never done any
media before this was just all
jumping in and just seeing how it went
yeah and it went wow yeah
yeah and because i did that rugby one so
i did the one on rugby and everyone we
said oh that was really good um we might
we should put you on trackside and talk
about sports odds and stuff so
i started doing trackside sports stuff
and then
as i got to know a few of the boys i had
a sports show on trackside for a while
and i'd get like
i got snakey into the trackside studio
one day
and scooter and floss and
i remember taking um tj pirinara in
there
and um you know tj's pretty staunch sort
of relaxed dude and we walked in and he
walked into the master control room
which is just a
sea of screens and dials and digits and
sliders
and he walked in and his face he just
went
wow he just he was so
amped and then and the people thought it
was awesome that tj thought that their
job was awesome and they said oh do you
want to have a go and he's going yeah
so he starts vision switching live track
side pictures and fading in and out
stuff
and he said when i'm done with rugby i
want to do this job
yeah so i did a bit of tv and stuff with
trackside and then trackside radio
started and i did a show with nisbo for
a long time on radio and um
yeah it's just and i did a lot of stuff
with um
tv and zed and news tv 3 and news talk
cb whenever they wanted a tab
angle or a melbourne cup angle and stuff
like that um
they just rung me i still get phone
calls today oh yeah
popular man and talk me through the
process of setting the odds as a senior
bookmaker i know
a lot of punters listen to this show so
they'd be interested to know
how the whole process works well
very different now to how it was i loved
how it was
it was very personal um you took it very
personally if your book lost money
um and that's the way it should be you
should treat it like your own money
because
when i became a bookmaker i pretty much
stopped betting because i was getting
the thrill
by being on the other side so i was
actually betting against the punter and
trying to massage the market so it's
old school but if you if you punter out
there i'd still do what
the way i did it um so basically if you
take super rugby for example
i'd get the hurricane squad when it's
named and then i'd pick my starting 15
and my bench and then every player i'd
mark out of ten
so for like the hurricanes i'd have
julie barrett ten out of ten
um your wings you let's say ben lam i'd
probably go
eight out of ten um julian savia
eight or nine out of ten and you'd work
your way through and so
all the players would be out of ten then
i'd have the bench out of twenty as a
collective
yeah i'd have the kicker out of ten um
and then i'd have the coaching staff
strength
out of ten and then you add all of that
up and you get a number so let's say
it's 180.
and then i'd do the same for the
highlanders and then you'd go through
all of that
um mark all of them marty banks are ten
but you you go through go through all of
that and they might come out at 171
yeah versus 180 so my starting point is
the hurricanes win by nine points
now that sounds crazy
that was that was my power ratings i
needed a starting point
yeah so i had a starting point of nine
and then you'd say okay
and then i'd have a whole lot of stats i
had in a spreadsheet
every single super rugby result from
1996 to 2006.
i'd have the weather conditions what the
score was at half time what the first
scoring play was who the referee was
i'd have everything yeah and um and
everything all had a different um
waiting and then homeground advantage
um how strong you are away from home so
like
uh the brumbies back then had an amazing
home ground advantage the crusaders had
an amazing homegrown advantage
um hurricanes not so much but the
hurricanes hurricanes crusaders games
for whatever reason
always to take the hurricanes and the
appointments start for some reason they
get up for christchurch games
and um yeah i know there's a and i
always remember there's a quote that
jerry collins gave me i
i asked them one day i said why do you
guys play so well
against the crusaders and he said in a
very non-racist way he said they don't
like brown man rugby
and which to me was like in their face
late tackles high shots
just rack them up and
so the hurricane wellington teams always
went really well
better than they should and i'm not
saying they won more but they they went
better than they should against
christchurch teams
and auckland teams always did well
against wellington teams whether it was
the blues or auckland and
and it was one of the things i tore my
hair out trying to figure out why that
was
but auckland seemed to get up for
wellington and wellington seemed to get
up for christchurch
it was a a really interesting really
interesting thing but
if if you're a punton you want to make
some money keep some stats um
like i always get asked you know what's
a good tip what's a good tip it's like
do your own work
get your own stats like when paul honest
was refereeing
uh three out of five games the first
offering play was a penalty
yeah well he liked to stamp his mark on
the game now it was a penalizable
offense
but some referees might just like to let
that go but he liked to be
i'm here i'm the boss penalty you know
and so always take first stoppage and
play and pull honest games
is a penalty and also take penalty tries
he loved the penalty try
poor homeless loved one
so at the end of the day you were
basically just choosing the numbers you
were putting the odds out
and then just waiting for the punters to
adjust them or move them at all
yes i'd come up with my prices and then
we'd have a in the old days it changed a
bit
we didn't do this for long but we'd get
all of the bookmakers and i'd have my
prices and i'd have the whiteboard
and uh and i'd say without telling them
my prices i just go around the room
because you want a layer of the land and
you want
what are the public expecting the price
to be yeah and so that'll give the
prices we'd debate it and i'd say to one
my final price i wouldn't often move
from mine but occasionally you would
but if you're a punter out there jimmy
and you're thinking i'm
i'm going to take the chiefs this
weekend i reckon they'll be
you know a dollar eighty i'll take them
and then i put them out at 220.
you're all over it so as a bookmaker
you're thinking well they take them at
180
why sell them at 220 if they'll be sold
at 180
and so the last thing i would do before
i put the prices in was
i've got to be happy as soon as i push
betting open i've got to be prepared to
take a ten thousand dollar bit
on either side so you know
all black south africa it's a dollar
twenty four twenty
so if the first bit in is ten thousand
on south africa we're going to lose 42
grand
am i happy to take that yeah and if i'm
not
i make a final little tweak and then
open it and then you put the seat belt
on and watch it come it's awesome
and i obviously um you would have got a
few wrong in your time i remember
one time in particular um i think i'd
mark taranaki at about three dollars to
win the comp
you opened them at 30 the complete
outsiders i couldn't believe it if i
could have punted i would have jumped
all over that one but
talk me through that big stuff up
yeah i didn't do that one
yeah like it's really hard like um
you'll get
for example let's use
manual two for example um they've just
signed a pretty big name it hasn't been
made
public yet but and i've only found out
sort of second hand but i know it's
happened
um so if we don't know that and we put
the markets out now
and then all of a sudden you hear that
i've signed this player this player and
this player and you've put them as rank
outsiders
and that's quite often what happens
especially with mitre 10
there's a lot of undisclosed and it's
not
intentionally undisclosed form but
signings and stuff like that
you know so you put a price out of
thirty dollars on taranaki
and people start punting it and then
three days later you found out that
bodenbari's been released and he's
playing the season for taranaki
of course it's wrong so it's a yeah
information is key eh
and but even in the final that yeah not
often you'd have the
away team as outsiders in a final but
that
that week you did you had tasman
favorites for the item cup final
talk me through that one that was
definitely you because i remember
talking to you before the game
yeah that was me that was me i believed
you know that you know
tasman and the oracle you know what
they were just on a roll i just there's
something
there's something about tasman and the
thing i like about tasman is every
province has got history
but tasman hasn't yeah but they're
developing a history
and they embrace that they are making
their history now
and i got wrapped up in that a bit i got
i got a bit
um emotionally invested in tavern i love
what they do
i love their fans i love their i love
the area
and this stadium um and that might have
swung me a little bit their way
yeah oh fair enough tasman can't beat
tasman to be fair
and talk to me about this um staff
specials i know a lot of people
um probably hit you up about them i
think i think most people think it's a
tip from you but
um you work for the tiv surely you don't
want these staff specials to be winning
too often
yeah no not well you do want them to win
you don't want to go
i think the worst was about six weeks in
a row it didn't come
in so it's it's it's marketing
um but we tried to find something
topical
so you'd have um the barrett brothers
versus the yuani brothers most points or
most tries or so or something like that
or if um i don't know
if james mark still got a uh i remember
one actually julie barrett got an
amazing kick from half
beyond halfway to win a game yeah so the
next game
the staff special is geordi barrett's
get a penalty over 50 meters because
it's topical
yeah so we work out what the actual
price
is like 2.75 and we go we'll make it
four
so the special every staff special
was value it was above the percentage of
it happening so
people would say you know we'd do the
odd special at 12
it's true price might have been eight so
an eight dollar
event is a twelve percent chance of
happening you know
so the true price is eight it's still
only a twelve percent chance of
happening but we're going to give you
twelve dollars instead of eight dollars
yeah so yeah they say oh your specials
are [ __ ] they don't come in and i'm not
saying they'll come in
but they have value but if you took it
every single time you will end up ahead
of the game
so if you're watching the game are you
wanting the staff special to come in or
not
yeah i do because it's got my name on it
so
and you and you don't you can go and
have a beer after the game rather than
go and hide in your hotel room
because you'll get shouted a few beers
if it comes in
but the funny thing was when it came in
i was a mug
and if it didn't come in i was an
[ __ ] so
but you obviously once you opened your
market you never wanted that market to
lose
um no it's it's funny you don't you
can't win all the time like
betting is a bit of a on the on the
bookmaker side it's a tune
right so you don't want to if you turn
over a million dollars
in a weekend we we would hope to make
150 000 profit
but and if we make a 450 000 profit
that's a great weekend
if you make 450 the next weekend and
then 450 the next weekend the punters
aren't having fun in the game
yeah so you don't mind the odd loss
like probably the best example was when
um david tour fought linux lewis
that's probably still the highlight of
my whole bookmaking career because
that did about 10 times what an all
black tested and turnover
and we had quite an old computer system
then and i was just sitting there
watching the numbers
and the liability on david tour just
going out the door
yeah and we'd laid off a lot of our
liability offshore
we put about quarter of a million
dollars offshore on david tour
and we were getting six dollars on him
offshore
and he was 2.75 in new zealand but
we were still losing nearly a million
dollars if david tua had a one
wow but in the end we were actually
happy to cop that million dollar loss
because there was so many first-time
bidders
yeah having a bet in that and so their
first
ever bet being a winner and then they
go back to the tab to cash in their
ticket it's a good
feeling experience yeah so yeah we made
a lot of money off their
fight but if we hadn't lost a lot we
would have made a lot of
new customers and that and that sort of
thing so did you ever have to do that
often go offshore
sort of cover your bets we used to a bit
actually and it was quite a common
practice back in the day but
we actually realized after a few years
we never made withdrawals from those
bookmaking accounts
yeah so and we sat down and we did a
feasibility test over about five years
and we got all of our transactions and
and we found that if we'd never laid off
we would have been better off
so we stopped and pretty much everyone
in the world stopped laying off
you'd only do it you do it very rarely
if it was like a like a huge
liability but um it swings in
roundabouts
true and talk to me about um a young
childhood hero of mine steel balls
i don't know if you you obviously
remember him he would have been uh
he would have sent the shivers at you a
few times but um any good stories about
him
yeah interesting a interesting character
like
most punters that have a decent win um
don't want to be publicised they don't
want people to know their big wins big
losses or anything
yeah and back in those days
on the sunday news i think it was on the
back page we had the top 10 bets of the
week
winners all those is just the biggest
puns and steel balls was on the back of
that each week
and um yeah he made his name and made
his
money off the five all black losses in a
row
when tayden randall was captain and i
think his first bet was something like
20 000 on the all blacks to lose
maybe three bucks so he got 60
and then he put the 60 on and they lost
and then he put the 120 on and they lost
and then he put the 200 on
and they lost so yeah and then he he
bought an amazing racehorse with the
loyal creek with the money
and um he was he was a character man and
um he went on the speaking circuit
talking about his punting
and and all that and he's actually a
good fellow yeah but
just um professionally
we couldn't sort of associate with them
you couldn't go and have a few beers
with them because it'd just look weird
you know it'd be like may
be like me going and having a beer with
bryce lawrence
you know while he was refereeing it'd
just look a bit sus you know
true big steel balls is he does he still
punt doesn't punt anymore did he lose at
all i
i don't know actually i don't know i
know he was um
selling cars in wellington for a while
but
yeah but he built a nice house and he
did all right but i i
actually yeah he certainly didn't bet to
the degree that he did back in his
heyday
yeah so now the biggest punters are
probably the whole boys get paid um
group now are they
are they boys get paid love it love it
mate if i if i like there's a um
privacy issue that i can't tell you
actual details but if you knew what the
biggest punters did
make your eyes water um but like
the top 10 punters of the tib and i'm
not talking now but
when i was up to here and
nine of them were offshore oh yeah yeah
yeah so how do they not get a restricted
account they're obviously losing quite a
bit because
i know restricted accounts are becoming
more and more common
um for successful punters or punters who
i guess punt a bit smarter what's the go
there how do these guys get such
big figures down um yeah so if you have
someone say i'll use my example
um like i'm a massive tour de france fan
i love the tour de france and i do all
my stats i do all my study
and um i opened an account at bet
365 and uh i had a bet on like stage
four
or five the first time that i went in
the mountains
and i put 20 pounds on a guy and he won
at 12s that's 240 pounds so i was quite
happy with that
and then the next night i put 50 pounds
on a guy
and he won he was only paying six so i
won 300 pounds and i got an email from
them
saying count closed not even restricted
closed
two bets
yeah but like the tab it's it's an
interesting thing like the tab do have
that right so if
you've got a business and you've got a
customer that is costing you money
um if do you want them as a customer are
they a valuable customer and people get
all
testosterone about it saying oh you've
got no bulls you've got no this you've
got no that
but it's like the supermarket sell
bottles of coke for a dollar
limit six otherwise you'd go and empty
the shelves and
sell them to you know the dairy owners
can only go and buy six so
it's we still want people to have fun
but
you know stable snow stuff um
you know sean maitland rings you and
says mate the scotland team have got
chicken pox we're putting out a b
team get on so you charge in and
and you take italy because they're going
to be playing scotland b
yeah italy are paying eight bucks you
put 10 grand on we're 80 grand in the
hole you've got the information we
haven't
yeah so it's it's a bit of a protection
thing but
bottom line is it's a company and it's
got to make money so
restricting people isn't the first go-to
but it probably is a necessary tool
fair enough and another thing you sort
of sort of touched on there was
fixing i guess or a little bit of
insight how much do you think goes on in
sport
how much are you guys aware of what are
your precautions
around that you've got a whole new
podcast
a whole new podcast i'm really
passionate about this i
like i'll try and give you a reader's
digest version i went to
a um i went to a conference in fiji
which sounds glamorous i was there for
two days
it never stopped raining like proper
raining the whole time but
fifa and interpol put on a conference
for keeping our
game clean or something like that and it
wasn't long after the
cricket was in the um spotlight for it
all
and i went over there and was put on by
oceania football so
there was a table from new zealand there
was me and another guy from work there
were about three cops
a couple of government employees a
sports lawyer
um referees bosses all that there was
our table at 10 and tonga had a table
cook island samoa papua new guinea so
all of australia were in there
and the head of interpol was there and
they told us about match fixing
over in europe and stuff and told us
real life stories and
holy [ __ ] this is this is unreal
like what is happening over there and
i've been privy to a bit of stuff
just you know and i can't really talk
but
there's stuff i know that's gone on and
i'm probably the only person in new
zealand that knows it
and i've chosen to keep it that way but
i met with a guy
declan hill and he wrote a book
called the fix and
read the book holy heck it's an amazing
if you're into sport and sports betting
read the facts by declan hill sport new
zealand brought declan hill out to new
zealand to address all these ceos and
chairs of all the sports
organizations and i went along to listen
to him because i'd read his book
and only four sports came along because
new zealand don't see it as a threat
and so then i said to declan how can i
grab a cup of coffee with you after your
presentation
just for 10 minutes and he said yeah so
went across to the intercontinental
house bar and had a coffee and i
i sat there for an hour with him telling
him what i'd seen
and he and he said i was the first guy
he'd ever met that understood both sides
of match fixing equation
yeah so like the bookmaker side and then
the punter side
and so it was nice to meet him and that
sort of thing and then he rang me that
night and he said i want to see you
again
and before i go back to the uk he's like
a professor so i flew back to wellington
and i had a day with him
oh man it was friggin mind blowing like
what he told me in confidence was just
unbelievable
like i guess i can tell you that um
like the biggest crime in the world now
like that the drug smugglers the weapons
traders and all of that dove all
the big players will chuck that in for
match fixing and
um like one story i'll tell you
that one story i'll tell you yeah go on
here we go
so there was it was um the malaysian
national
football team yeah um approached the la
galaxy
football team for a friendly as a
warm-up for the asian cup
and they sent them a letter and
contacted la galaxy and said look we'll
we'll pay for the high ridge of the
stadium in la
um we'll pay your players a you know a
fee and we'll have this game
and to help us warm up blah blah blah
and these are the dates we can do it and
and then they said oh you come and see
us so the the president
flew over and went and saw them and they
signed the deal and it was all done and
then about two months later the
malaysian team went over played
la galaxy um la galaxy won four one
and then malaysia went back it then came
out that it wasn't the malaysian
national football team it was just a
match fixer guy
who'd made up a letterhead and had a
bunch of players on
take and they put copy malaysian
national jerseys on them
took this team to la and said there
needs to be five goals in this game
they punted it on the black market to be
five or more goals
and it more than covered all the
expenses and everything and he made
millions
wow that is crazy it's
awesome there obviously can't be too
much of that going on not too many teams
would be that
clueless oh look it's amazing well there
was a
there's a very famous cricketer who was
who was they were touring england
an international cricketer and him and
his manager
um were in the house bar and this guy
came up to them and said
i'm so and so from i think was adidas
adidas or puma i can't remember one of
one of those brands gave them the card
um and he was the marketing manager for
india
for this brand yeah and this team where
after england were going to go in tour
india and they said we we just want you
to put a sticker on your bat
and wear our clothes and stuff like that
just for the indian tour and we'll give
you
like 20 grand a test or whatever
a nominal amount and blah blah and so
they had to talk and they said yeah okay
so they signed the deal so when we go to
india you contact us
and they said um so they went out for
dinner and a drink to celebrate
and then the player and his manager were
in the hotel and then
and the indian adidas rep said i've got
to get get going he says i've left a
gift for you in your room
so the player went up to his room and
there was a bag of
money on his bed and a russian hooker
and what they do and thankfully the
player didn't avail himself if the
russian hooker
went and reported it to the team manager
and what so it was a fake
indian adidas rep with a fake business
card
and they'd put hidden cameras into his
room
and so they were going to capture him
having sex with this
woman and then blackmail him when he got
to india with the tapes they had of him
because he was a married man so it's
it's it's way more than just fixing
sports events it's now blackmail
and so it's called the it's called the
honey trap
and um and a few cricketers have been
caught by the honey trap one
the one in particular who was at the top
of his game
got caught in the honey trap and
retired young with a chronic knee injury
that would never allow him to play
against knee injury
never played again wow
cricket that's just the tip of the
iceberg of my fixing storage
obviously cricket's a easier sport to
fix than most so cricket would be a huge
target for those guys do you think
it's ever going to get into rugby or do
you think it's inter got into rugby
i don't think it's in rugby um
but i'll give you an example of i mean
years ago years and years ago
i got a phone call um
an anonymous phone call from someone and
said hey i'm just letting you know
that in the game on saturday errol
brain's going to score the first try the
team's going to set it up for errol
brain to score the first trial of
counties
yeah and and it was a ramp early shield
game against
and i i still can't remember whether it
was east coastal poverty but it was a
low low
third division team or something like
that yeah
and i said oh yeah whatever and i didn't
even know what match fixing was that's
how long ago it was
and so instead of opening up like the
number eight and a one-sided game
might sort of be 16 18 first try scorer
so i opened it at 15.
as soon as i opened money started coming
in on and i went to 12
then i went to 10. he ended up paying
less than the wings
he was like five or six bucks with a
decent liability but back then a decent
liability was only five grand on a
shitty game like that
yeah um and and i was just thinking this
is weird this is weird
how does everyone know this and then the
game kicked off and
counters were all over them and then the
wing made a break for counties and he
had about a 60 meter unchallenged
run to the sideline to to the try line
he was about 15 meters clear of anyone
and he got five meters short of the line
and you saw him think
and he just went the ground just dropped
it's you know how you're doing training
you just set up the fake mall
and he just dropped and placed the ball
and everybody comes careering in
and then they trap to the ball in the
bottom five meter scrum
knowing oh you are kidding it's going to
be a push-over try this is what the
plan was so they have the scrum and it
collapsed
and then they have another scrum and it
collapsed and the ref gave a penalty try
so they all lost they all
but they were just putting like 10 or 20
bucks on each for a piss trip so it
wasn't like
a big organized illegal stinger it was
it was quite innocent you know i've seen
a couple of games in new zealand
again not recently a long time ago first
scoring play drop goal
and teams taking drop goals in the first
minute then you're just going oh
okay okay yeah but the one
um at the bulldog did you were you
involved with that at all
yeah i was um i was actually
uh that was um bulldogs against north
queensland
and um we would get starting to get
money
on um first scoring play being
a north queensland penalty yeah
and anyone that watches any rugby
leaguers they only take a penalty when
time's up on the clock pretty much
or when it's real close and first
scoring play hardly ever happens
and then when a bit comes in that
goes through a certain threshold it's
intercepted onto our computer so it's
not automatically accepted and it came
up
and someone wanted five thousand dollars
on first scoring play being a north
queensland penalty it was paying 10
bucks
so it's a 50 grand loser yeah i mean we
don't normally hold five grand on the
whole book let alone
one bit yeah and i thought oh they've
made a mistake on the
bet slip so i just went they probably
took
the times thousands so i gave them fifty
dollars yeah and it cancelled and then
five thousand came on and i said oh
this is weird so i rang the agency while
the bet was on my screen and just said
do they really want five thousand
dollars on first good do they know what
they're doing
and then he said i'll just ask her and i
went her
so it's not a sexist thing but very
rarely do you get a woman wanting a five
thousand dollar bet for scoring play on
a rugby league game
and i just said i know look she can't
have it she can have 100 bucks
and then so um didn't take it so i
suspended the book and then i rang a
mate of mine that works for a bookmaker
in australia
yeah and i said davey i said
are you getting any action on the first
scoring play
penalty to the uh to the to the cowboys
and he said yeah just now
and i said so we and he said [ __ ] so he
he
we're all and all the bookmakers are in
this network so
that that option in that
that selection and that option was
suspended right through australasia
yeah yeah and then we ended up just
closing the um book
and people were saying they wanted to
have a bet on it we just said our
technical difficulties we can't
do anything about it um and we've got
cameras and all the tabs and pub tabs
and i got a look at the person that was
putting on it was a
i don't know she would have been in her
20s had a pram with a baby in it and it
just didn't stack up you know
so then i watched the game and um
i watched the game and it was like three
or four minutes and
cowboys on attack in front of their post
ryan tandy makes a tackle and just lies
on the guy
you know he's going get up get up get up
and he's lying lying lying like
blow and he blew it right in front
and i'm like oh my god and um jonathan
thurston
saw there was a massive overlap out to
the left so tapped it and
double skip past try in the corner so
bloody idiots tried to go through with
it so
they must have known that we were on to
them but they still tried to do it
do you know how much money they managed
to get on obviously they didn't get any
from you guys but what about around the
world do you know uh
not much at all like i think when i say
not much i
think about 50 000 and collects
but they didn't collect that because it
was so bloody obvious
yeah and the next day i got a call from
um new south wales police
um so they'd rang the bookmakers and
they said oh this is the guy that found
it and so they rung me
and they were going to fly a guy over to
talk to me i said man
i haven't got much to say you know this
is what happened and we can give you the
footage and it's turned out that the
woman was the sister
of either tandy's flatmate or
tandy's agent's flatmate or something
like that but um
yeah they went to jail and uh got
convicted and
ryan tandy ended up with the wrong crowd
and he yeah
he either overdosed or yeah killed
himself yeah yeah so it was it was an
absolute
shocker crazy mate so many so many
stories in that scene
behind the scenes hey it's crazy yeah
you're definitely going to have to write
a book one day
i i would love to write a book but
um you know i've had three people ask me
to
to do a book and i said i i couldn't
tell you everything you know and
and they said oh we won't say who who
it's by and i said there's only one
person that can tell you the stories i
can tell you
and it's going to be obviously me i said
unless you can pay me a million
dollars and give me new identity and
i'll go and live in the jungle in
thailand or something
but yeah i'd love to i'd love to do it
though oh yeah
geez that would be a good read
anyway we could talk about match fixing
and gambling for years on that
if you love it
i actually wasn't i was i was so glad
all right we'll get to this but um
2020 obviously got made redundant from
the tab i was so gutted not only for you
but
i also wanted to jump onto that scene as
well and come join me
sitting next to you in wellington and
the officers making those odds but
um we will talk about um the 2020 i know
it was a
horrible year for you pretty much
everything that could have gone wrong
did go wrong and um a real tough year
for you mentally
how did you handle it and talk me
through the year
um yeah it was a tough all year like
i mean no one predicted the covert thing
and when it sort of started rearing its
head in sort of
february march and we were just going oh
there's something happening overseas and
then
it all happened quite quick and we we
sort of went into lockdown
and i think it was late march wasn't it
we went into lockdown
and pretty much all sporting events
around the world just stopped
horse racing here stopped aussie
horse racing was about the only thing
that kept going
um we were doing betting on um ukrainian
underwater tonsil hockey and you know
all sorts of random things and we were
just everyone was just stuck at home you
know no one was going into the office
and you know i just lived by myself and
i started going a bit crazy the first
week was great just sitting at home
and yeah we were doing zoo meetings with
the work fellas and we were
having fun with as i say uzbekistan
table tennis
and volleyball from random places and um
yeah and then we've been sort of i think
we locked down for five weeks didn't we
yeah and then
um in the fourth week we were having
zoo meetings with our ceo and
he was doing the best he could and but
no one had any answers no one knew how
long it was going to take but
the tib was just bleeding money
like same as a number of businesses the
costs don't stop
um but the income did and so we're a
high income high expense company
and when the high income stocks and the
high expenses don't
you're just bleeding money every week
yeah and
um i remember on a
tuesday we had a zoom with um the ceo
and you could send in questions and
there's redundancies on the cards
because it was starting to be talked
about around new zealand no we're not
we're not thinking about that
that yet and then on thursday or friday
we were told yep there's going to be
some redundancies there's going to be a
restructure you'll be contacted by your
managers and then i got a phone call on
the
monday morning and saying you've been
disestablished and i'm like holy [ __ ]
excuse me and they disestablished
i think it was something like 220 out of
600 stuff
so third just just over a third yeah um
no warning just happened bang like that
and
and that sort of rocks me and um
i was numb for like a day i just didn't
quite know how to process that
because the country's in lockdown you've
just lost your job
and then you have to have a negotiation
process
and blah blah so you stay on for about
another three weeks
but no one could do anything and you
knew you were going
and um yeah it was horrible was
it was about about three weeks later and
um
i think we'd gone into um
level four uh level three so people
could go out again
and i'd go back to work take my laptop
my phone my car
my security pass and i felt like i was
just
giving my life away you know and then i
just sort of
i hired a car for a week um and then
came home and thought
now what do i do you know you i just
lost
i sort of lost my identity in a way in
there
and my phone when i didn't tell everyone
straight away i just
i just didn't feel the need to tell
everyone told my family and a couple of
mates and
and then it was starting to filter out
that i'd lost my job and
i'd started painting during lockdown as
well
and i was doing a particular painting
and and my phone was going ding
oh mate i heard you lost your job sorry
if there's anything i can do
oh thanks mate blah blah blah get back
to painting ding oh sorry to hear about
your unsee stuff
so and um i think someone had put on
facebook can't believe to
be let steph go or something like that
so i did a facebook post and i don't do
videos of myself and all that but i
thought this will just stop my phone
dinging
so i can finish my painting so i did it
i did a video and um i was just
basically saying you've lost my job
cheers
see ya and then just at the end of the
video i just said actually
if if you've got a friend or a family
member who's been made redundant and is
going through what i'm going through
here's some
some tips you can do for them because
this is what i need and so maybe that's
what they need
so i did the video and sent it out and
then carried on painting my phone just
kept dinging and i thought oh they'll
see the
message and about 20 minutes later
coming back and there's like 150
messages
like private messages off that facebook
post from complete strangers
yeah saying thank you so much for that
my brother lost his job i didn't know
what to do and all i said to them was
you don't have to give them answers you
just have to listen just have two ears
and just listen and just sit next to
them don't don't try and fix their life
yeah um because in their mind they're
like [ __ ] so just let them think that
for a while
and and just be there for them and um
and i remember like
the great man ross felipe so
one of the great in fact i'll get to
that shortly so not long after i was
made redundant my sister
had been um having chemo and she was in
hospital during lockdown
not doing well again a long story short
she they said she was terminal and
they said you can either stay in
hospital you can go to hospice or you
can go home
and she said i just want to go home
she'd been in hospital for four months
so they stopped all of her drugs
she had three really good days at home
and then three
terrible days at home and then passed
away and
so i lost my job and then i lost my
sister there was no funeral we couldn't
go there she
husband couldn't get back and then the
next week my older sister was diagnosed
with cancer with bowel cancer
and i was just like holy holy [ __ ] and i
was just dealing
i was dealing with them one at a time so
i was made done and i was devastated
then my sister died i didn't care about
being made redundant
and then my sister died and then my
older sister got diagnosed and then i
was
more worried about her and worried about
my mum and dad
and then ross filippo rung me and it was
about nine o'clock at night and i was
sitting on my back step
and it was the first time i'd addressed
it all collectively
like it all actually happened not one
thing had happened
and one thing and it was all
collectively no i was a blubbering idiot
for 20 minutes i couldn't talk for 20
minutes and he just sat there
every minute or so he'd just say i'm
here bro
that's it i'm still here 20 minutes of
silence just with a mate on the end of
the foe you know and
and i didn't feel better afterwards but
um i needed i needed that outlet and
that to me illustrated that you just
need someone to be
you don't need them to fix you or do
that you don't need answers you just
you just need to share the ear with
someone sort of thing
and then it was just like [ __ ] you know
oh and then just before my sister died
um
and actually just after i saw you and
wellington i was doing my redundancy
road trip
my best mate died in invercargill um
he was diagnosed motor neurone disease
in
february and you usually live two to
four years or something he
he lasted three or four months he got
pneumonia and
just didn't have the lung strength and
passed away so i was driving down to
see him and i'd got as far as
queenstown um i'd spent the night before
with ben hearing one of the great nights
in wanaka
and and um yeah he'd be a good potty
mate oh
get jamming on um yeah and then i got to
queenstown i rang his wife she said oh
it's not very good and i said i'll come
down now if you like
and she said i know he'll be okay i'm
just going to ring the nurse if there's
anything more i can do for him and then
she texts me
10 minutes later said he just died so i
just jumped straight in the car
and drove to invercargill and so i had
the week of a week of that and
at the end of that week and then i was
going to work my way back up the country
visiting
friends and family that i'd lost touch
with them all that i was really looking
forward to it but
after the funeral on this saturday i
woke up on the sunday and i was going to
spend a few days in invercargill with
his wife and daughter but
i had nothing i was i was done
i was absolutely done and i got in the
car
the weirdest thing i drove to
christchurch i was going to stop in
dunedin for a couple of days but i
didn't
i drove to christchurch pulled into the
motel
walked into my room and i didn't
remember one thing of the drive
you know and it's that's a six seven
hour drive i remember
i didn't remember any of the cities i
didn't remember anything
at all yeah and um i arrived and i
um actually messaged brad moore oh yeah
the the now assistant all black coach
who's one of the great men
and i said are you around and he said
yep are you in town and i said yep and
he said meet me here at ten o'clock
so we went to this cafe at ten o'clock
and um
and i didn't tell him what had been
going on with me for a while he knew i'd
lost my job we just sort of talked about
that
and um he's just such a good man just a
good such a good positive man and then i
tried to catch up with tim bateman down
there as well but he was busy
at work and stuff and he's another good
and i've learned that i just needed to
um be with puzzle be with good people
and it's people in my position and i
felt it for a while you feel like you're
burdening someone when you go to them
and say mate i'm having
problems and i thought who what gives me
the right to
burden someone with all these deaths and
um job losses and and stuff but
you know when i started my trip um
like i i caught up with a friend in
rotherham
someone else in hawke's bay caught up
with shannon paku
caught up with you and wellington and
just just sitting down having a coffee
with you that was just good for me
yeah just just to be with be with a good
person and then that gave me fuel to go
to the next one and
like people say how did how did you get
through it
i actually don't think i did i don't
think i have
yeah and you know how everyone says um
what doesn't kill you make stronger and
you climb the mountain you'll reach the
top and all that
not everyone does yeah you know i've
actually failed to deal with it
and i accept that i've failed to deal
with it i actually don't think i'll deal
with my sister's
passing until i'm with her husband
but he's a british national and can't
get into new zealand he's applied twice
on compassionate grounds he's got her
ashes she wants them on the beach where
my parents live
but he can't get into new zealand but
it's awesome the wiggles can
own the west indies cricket team and uh
but hey yeah i'm not going to get all
bitter about that but i don't think i'll
probably grieve
fleur until her husband's been here
my other sister that was diagnosed
cancer she's finished her treatment
she's doing really well
which is good i've
i've got a short-term contract with uh
tvz for the america's cup
so that's amazing mate like before
that would just be a thing now it's a
win yeah
you know so you've got to view it as a
win like my hours at tvnz are long
they're full on it's hard but i love it
yeah because i'm part of a team and i'm
contributing and that's what i really
really missed
yeah you know there was a no worse
feeling
waking up on a monday with no job
no one's ordered a painting no money in
the bank
and you're like what the [ __ ] am i going
to do today
that that was hard that was reality
biting you know i applied for like
30 jobs i got two letters
and 28 nothings you know it was um
[ __ ] it was demoralizing yes i bet and
you talked about your painting you're
obviously a very gifted painter where
did that come in and was that
was that a bit of an outlet for you i
know i've seen a lot of your work and
it's impressive so if any waterloo
listeners want to buy something
yeah and he said oh stephanie will do an
absolute treat for you
yeah it's um it's taken off eh
it's um it's a little bit quiet at the
moment like
work creates work and so i do a painting
i put it on social media and it'll make
someone go oh i wonder if he could do
that wonderfully he could do my cat
wonder if he could do my horse
yeah what if he could do my favorite
rugby player and um i actually
i was taught by my maths teacher at
palmy boys
he taught me to do one painting because
i wanted to buy a painting on his wall
and he said no i come back
after school i'll teach you how to do it
so he taught me how to do it and i did
it
and with david bowie and it was
there it is look at that
that's a copy of the one i did at school
so the one i did at school broke
a long time ago and then bowie died and
my sisters all messaged me and said
you've still got the bowie painting i
said nah it broke years ago
and then that night i was thinking i
wonder if i could do it again so i
bought a canvas and did it again and i
went oh yeah that was quite fun and then
i was doing like
a painting every three or four months
not for anyone just for
shits and giggles and then i did a
michael jackson one
and um you know about five people
messaged me on facebook i put it on
facebook because i thought
that's come out quite cool just put it
on facebook and these five people wanted
to buy it within half an hour so i sold
it
and then i just started doing the odd
one and then in lockdown i just started
painting just for um
not for therapy for what was going on
but probably more
just for a mental holiday just to stop
worrying about [ __ ] all the time
and it was good and then yeah and then
i've slowly been
painting more and more and i just
painted one the other day of
an all black from 1937 which was a guy's
grandfather kicking a goal at the scg
um yeah and i've got one i don't know if
i'm allowed to show you that one that's
on my wall i've done
i've got a nice little contract jimmy
with an outfit in wellington i'm doing
20
um athletes and oh [ __ ] it i'll show you
can you see that oh yeah oh how good is
that
yeah yeah so um that one's going on a
wall
in wellington and i'm doing about 20
over the next 18 months
and um and i've had the auckland racing
club
i'm talking to them on monday about
doing one live on auckland cup day or
derby day in front of the stand which
should be a bit of a challenge
um well that's the thing like that
rowing one probably took me
seven or eight hours oh yeah so i i
don't want to be eligible for seven or
eight hours painting a bloody
horse or whatever it is i might have to
start it at home and then finish it
there or something
so but it's good it's good yeah i do
enjoy it and
yeah it's fun and what about your
podcast staff chat
how's that going if you've got many
plans for that
um i've got kevin barry booked for next
week have you oh that'll be good
yeah so for an hour podcast i'll
probably need three questions
[Laughter]
yeah i've been i've been trying to get
him for like two or three years but he
lives in vegas
and um he's incredibly busy but i
actually saw him this morning
went to a sparring session with joe
parker and
um i said when are we going to do the
podcast and he blamed me
i've been chasing him for years and he
said you've never given me a time
okay tuesday morning so yes i'll be
recording that next week um just over
the last few months i found it really
hard not for motivation but just
um just getting stars to a line you know
i've done i've done a few
um but i'd like to do one a fortnight so
once i get another one in the can mate
i'll be i'll be back up and running but
it's
interesting the back catalog is still
getting heaps of downloads eh because i
try and make them timeless
yeah you know and you've got some unreal
guests that you've had on already oh so
some of the great
some of the great guests yeah and i felt
like i'm a massive podcast listener and
i quite often find the ones i enjoy the
most are the people i haven't heard of
yeah um and like one of my favorite ones
of the staff chat one was julian dean
yeah who's pro well he is new zealand's
best ever road cyclist and his stories
about the tour de france and stuff
now people don't it's one of the least
downloaded
because people go julian dean haven't
heard him scroll yeah
you know and then they'll go and listen
to justin marshall andrew merton's
you know and the big names and not good
yarns
but um learning stuff about so like
you're one with flinny the other
that i listened to the other day was
just off the hook i've got no idea who
he was but
what a story what a story
yeah he had a story all right and he had
no filter so it was a good one
no filter bro yeah oh but what a story
you've had and what a journey um
yeah really appreciate you coming on and
sharing all of that but as always we've
gone to
um the instagram for some questions
and a good face of the tab lots of
messages have come in for you
oh dear
let me find that where is it
here he is okay
first question would you rather the
turbos when the randfill is shield or
the all blacks win their next world cup
turbo shield all day all day
i was there the day i was the other day
they lost it
in 1978 and i will not go to my grave
until i'm there the day they've won it
i've been to every
shield challenge since 1978 except two
really well committed you are committed
because and now they've got those
couple of secret signings this could be
the year
wait for the signing that's going to
come out soon
[Laughter]
okay i've signed an all black there you
go i'll tell you that oh
geez the teaser how much does it the tab
love it when there's a draw in a match
must be a
bumper payday yeah
generally it is like a rugby match yeah
i remember once um
before there was multibits we used to do
winning team and margin double
so you can go this team travel and draw
draw
sort of paid about well moon money like
five six hundred bucks and one weekend
in super rugby the two games we'd put in
the multi was a draw draw
no one had it the next weekend everyone
took it
we were like losing a gazillion dollars
but nine of them was a draw
but generally yep drawers and drawers
are pretty good yeah
not the draw half time full time because
that's quite popular but the drawer full
time by itself is alright yeah the half
time one happens quite often uh
okay three sportsmen that you'd love to
go on a night out with
or on a night out okay so it's not just
me just like have a proper night out
yeah uh
charles barclay oh
um cristiano ronaldo
jeez um just because
his off-casts would be like incredible
and uh
one more
marty banks oh great choice
yeah sure because you can't you can't be
the ugliest one in the group
[Laughter]
that's true okay most embarrassing tv
blunder you've made
oh i remember once when justin marshall
was playing
and we were doing the pre-game and
off-camera
like i've told justin marshall this
myself actually but when he was playing
i thought he was an
absolute wanker i couldn't
couldn't stand them and we were talking
off camera i can't remember who i was
talking to
and i'd use the c word when i was
talking about justin
yeah um and then it was like all of a
sudden i was on live
and i turned around and i said well it's
no surprise to the favorites tonight i
come from
canterbury
yeah so i said the c word on tv that was
pretty bad
pretty bad oh that's good stuff okay the
most surprising sports character that
you've met
um what you thought they'd be like
versus what they were
yeah first time i met him
i booked an interview with him for sky
and
and i said oh hey mars he's walking past
he goes i don't have to talk to you
and i said oh who do you think you are
and he went oh
okay okay and i just stood up to him
yeah and we became
we became friends and uh
so he he'd always come across as a brash
arrogant
um bully all of that he is
one of the softest nicest blokes does
heaps for kids heaps for charities
really cares and as an example a few
years later i was doing a story
for skye he must have been bringing up
100th game or something we were up at
his house
yeah and i've been going for ages and i
said mate can we just pause because he
lived by the airport i said i've just
got to pop down and pick up my parents
from the airport they're coming back
from australia yeah and he said oh yeah
we'll go in my car
so we jumped into his car and drove to
the airport and he said
when they come through what's their
names i said bruce in virginia
and he said when they come through point
them out and so they come through the
doors
from international i said those two
there and he goes bruce virginia
it's like
[Laughter]
grabs all their bags and put it on the
ute and and they came up and watched the
rest of the filming made them a cup of
tea
and away we went what sort of bloke he
was
yeah yeah so he was the most surprising
yeah for sure he's definitely he
definitely has the
stereotype of a person who he's not
actually is isn't he
yeah sure okay
what is your best and worst moment
working with ants on head heart and
balls
a lot of people love head heart and
balls
yeah we're fishing at making a comeback
with that oh yeah just
just quietly yeah um best and worst
moments
probably the best was the day he had a
nose operation at hospital
on the morning of the show and he
discharged himself and walked in and did
the show with the drip
that they'd had up his nose hanging out
his hospital gown on nothing on
underneath because the hospital's just
up the road from the studio
and full of morphine and did a show
that was probably the worst was probably
all of the others because he
he he's 24 hours he glistens
with perspiration he's the most sweating
human and i and an ex-girlfriend told me
that his underpants are made of shammy
material because he sweats so much
yeah how bad is that
oh what a lad
okay uh next question best multi you've
heard of
oh best multi i've heard of was
probably i'm going to guess the
amount of time ago i'm going to go about
eight years ago
and it was a race meeting at ellsley
between
boxing day new year somewhere around
there and a guy took
an eight leg horse multi
and then he took seven leg a six leg and
a five
leg seven of them seven out of eight one
and he told a few of his mates what he'd
done and they did it as well
and um seven of them went if eight
of them had of one it would have been
millions but it was like 850 grand
and he only i outlaid about 500 bucks
true
yeah geez that's good stuff was it all
in the same meeting
yeah yeah back-to-back races oh yeah
[Laughter]
okay next one favorite ground to present
on
oh forsyth bar as that yeah
like the zoo is
it takes you back to not childhood but
early adulthood like
the zoo crowd are so awesome like
they are juiced but not once that i see
trouble not once that i see a fight
it was like good humor great drunk
students first years and all that
so much so one year they said come and
watch the game with us because
um so i said okay they always used to
see me and chant my name and
and all that sort of stuff and it wasn't
an ego thing it was just a good fun and
then
i particularly remember one day i was
standing there and i said and the floor
manager would go when he says such a
word i want you to all wave your flag so
i'd say the highlanders and i turn
around and say the hollows and that
always be flex
but as soon as i started there was a
group of about 12 guys
and they're just banging on the fence
staff is a good [ __ ]
and it was crystal clear through the
microphones
so we went up and watched the game with
them and then they said come back to the
halls for a few jars so
i was back at the bloody first year
university students all
getting on the sauce with the boys of
the girls and it was awesome it was all
just good clean fun
no scratch no but oh the atmosphere
there is off the hook it's an amazing
playing surface
there's club sandwiches there's sushi in
the photographer's room
you know happy days they need more
they're more
need more stadiums like that around new
zealand oh boy do they yeah
okay what's your favorite thing to do in
thailand you mentioned thailand earlier
in the
pod so that's my yeah i've um
probably been i've probably been there
six or seven times uh
three of them i went to well it sounds
weird but i love going to muay thai
boxing camps so
three of my trips that's what i did yeah
so
uh for three weeks stints and you just
get
just go crazy it starts at six in the
morning yeah
with a two hour muay thai training
session and then you have breakfast then
you do a
two-hour um like cardio or weight
session then you have lunch then you do
two hours muay thai
then you do yoga and then you cooked um
i sometimes took the
afternoon off and went to the beach
though but it's awesome you know it's
all and it and it's away from all the
tourist hot spots it's yeah as well it's
right at the southern tip of phuket
so you know i love thailand i love the
thai people
um but away from the touristy areas yeah
i wasn't expecting that answer but
that's good stuff
okay three most underrated players
you've watched that should have been all
blacks
wow should have been all blacks that's a
goodie
yeah should have been all blacks
wow james and tom
[Laughter]
should have been all blacks i reckon
david howell would
should have been could have gone real
close only at a little bit more speed
yeah um he was quite absolute quality
yeah um so he'd be one um
gee that's hard uh
maybe jamie booth oh yeah he will be
though
those teams might be getting a little
bit old now i love jamie booth
he'd go good in the all blacks i reckon
yeah um
and someone like uh
so many get all black tests now either
yeah
it's pretty easy to name three that
shouldn't have but um
uh i can't think of another one jimmy
that's all right
i'd go way back to dale atkins who
couldn't get rid of zinzan brook and
buck shelford but that's a long time ago
but
he sounds like a lad
okay next question oh from reggie goods
what's your thoughts on breeding future
sports stars
eg llamo vs valerie adams not a great
example from normie but
i'm looking forward i'm looking forward
to richie and gemma mccoy's offspring
hi holy hecker yeah that'll be
phenomenal
dan carter and honor as well oh an honor
yeah
true you know they've got like four or
four
three and one more one more on the way
jeez yeah that'll be that oh yeah are
you a fan of it
breeding sports stars not intentionally
i see they're doing it they're doing
some of that in china right that's the
next big thing is um
yeah breeding athletes right i've heard
that in china they when
when you're like a teenager they come
and test your vo2 max your height your
weight your wingspan and all that and
say right you're a volleyball
go yeah they find out the right size and
shape yeah
yeah i don't mind if it happens
incidentally but not intentionally
i'm just concerned which athlete rich
good's as good as i on
okay who's winning this year's super
rugby
um
i'm sort of crusaders
again um just because that's the safe
thing to say i think the blues might
give it a shake hey
whoops there goes my i'm on sorry i
think the blues might give it a shake
yeah fair enough what about the canes
yeah good semi-finalists
there's no semi-finals this year
good top four side
okay last question if you could give one
piece of advice to someone who's going
through a tough time at the moment what
would it be
ah that would be
don't expect answers today or solutions
today
or tomorrow and it's just like people
say take it a day at a time
well for me like a day's too long it's
like
go down to 10 minute blocks i got down
to 10 minute blocks
like for the next 10 minutes i'm going
to wash the dishes
wash the dishes to win sounds stupid
but it's just those baby steps and
and just things will come right i mean i
still haven't got a full-time job i've
nearly been unemployed for like
eight months now we're not unemployed
but you know what i mean i want a
full-time meaningful job and just
you know it'll happen keep keep surging
keep charging keep
doing things and find little things that
you like like painting as i say was
it's not going to fix it but it gives
you a mental holiday and
take those little mental holidays if
it's golf if it's walking a dog
if it's throwing a frisbee if it's
making muffins if it's just
just have little things with nice little
ones
and acknowledge the win yeah acknowledge
the one and then set up your next one
even if it's
hanging you're washing out you know
doesn't have to be winning gold medals
yeah jeez that's powerful stuff and
great advice from the
man himself well really appreciate you
coming on the
podcast steffi it's obvious i've
obviously got to know you a little bit
throughout the career
loved seeing you before games loved
coming up and having a quick guarantee
before kickoffs and
seeing what the staff special was or
getting the odds off
um yeah your smiley face is infectious
and
you're just a really good person genuine
good guy who's willing to help
anyone out and really appreciate you
giving up your time and
sharing your story so honestly and i'm
sure a lot of
listeners will get a lot out of that so
yeah really appreciate you coming on
mate
yes jimmy may you need a painting for
that wall behind you too by the way it's
very beer
let's sort something out mate i'll be in
touch okay
all right buddy my phone was just dying
it was like 20
then 10 that's why i kept going black
yeah we made it
hey thank you for that no worries
brother that was awesome
appreciate it thanks take care see ya